the 2023 X-Force threat intelligence
index including info on back doors
ransomware and fishing all on this
episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
it's officially that time of year again
and IBM X-Force has released their
annual threat intelligence index a
comprehensive analysis of all their
research data from January to December
of 2022. and it included literally
billions of data points so this thing is
Big folks now we do this as a resource
for clients policy makers researchers
and the security industry in general
because today's volatile landscape with
its increasingly sophisticated and
malicious threats requires a
collaborative effort to protect
businesses and citizens
these essential research insights and
recommendations can help you respond to
attacks with greater speed and
effectiveness
the report is absolutely packed with
important information so we're going to
limit the discussion in this episode to
three main topics backdoors ransomware
and fishing
to start the most common action on
objective taken by threat actors in 2022
was the deployment of back doors with a
21 share of incidents reported
as a refresher action on objective is a
term we in cyber security borrowed from
the military and refers to the action an
intruder takes to achieve their goals
now back doors are often precursors to
ransomware events detecting back doors
before ransomware is deployed gives us
an opportunity as Defenders to prevent
the catastrophic impact of ransomware
encrypting a bunch of systems it also
helps prevent the double extortion
techniques that threat actors are using
while many organizations have a broad
view of the threat landscape xforce
recommends organizations adopt a view
that emphasizes the specific threat
actors that are most likely to Target
your industry organization and geography
next let's look at ransomware ransomware
attacks have gotten much faster which
means there must be faster responses
in fact the average duration of a
ransomware attack has gone from a little
over two months to just a little over
three days
when things are moving that quickly the
best defense is to be prepared attacks
are inevitable but failure doesn't have
to be
organizations should develop incident
response plans customized to their
environment those plans should be
regularly drilled and modified as the
organization changes the focus on
improving response remediation and
recovery time
finally let's talk a little about
fishing
remote work is fueling another spike in
email-based threats and phishing Remains
the leading infection Vector with 41 of
the share
one particular method that saw a
significant rise last year was thread
hijacking the
threat actors reply to recent email
threads to trick your friends family and
co-workers into providing access to
sensitive information data or systems
essentially they're creating a chain
reaction with potential victims even
worse free chat Bots and AI services
like chat GPT are making these threats
harder to detect
to prevent similar incidents from
happening in the future it's important
to understand the root cause of the
incident this may involve a combination
of technical procedural and human
factors so a comprehensive approach is
necessary to identify all potential
causes
to get the full rundown on all the 2022
research around back doors ransomware
fishing and much much more make sure you
download the new threat intelligence
index from the link in the description
of this video
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now